nicole rodin saying if you had to pick a
new name for yourself what name would
you pick I would pick JimBob because I
just I think it would be hilarious to
say hey my name is Jim Bob Pakman I'm an
Argentinian jus and I think that would
just to get a reaction from people i
think it'd be pretty funny yeah that's
fantastic i mean it's so tough because
pat is my identity now vegan producer
pat is the identity so to change it i
can't even imagine that but if i was to
change it it would be just something
completely out there ubaldo maybe had
been something like that Edmund yeah
that's interesting i wonder why there
can't be that can't be totally random
there must be some reason you said
Edmund it just came to my mind I am you
know I have a lot of random thoughts in
my head and I was the one that came I'm
kind of kidding about JimBob but I did
find out that my name was so had I been
born a girl I was going to be Jessica
Jessica Pakman which would be
interesting but the second option for my
first name as a boy behind David was max
which may not be shocking to a lot of
people a based on my family background
max Pakman I kind of like that I know I
really good this could be the max pakman
show right now but my entire my entire
world would be different if I was max
pakman right coming from an Irish family
there's a dude as you would imagine more
than one Patrick so my step-brother and
some of his cousins started calling me
pc which takes the p for my first name
in the f from my last name right and I
thought at first if I just kind of
ignore this it'll fizzle out it'll go
away that's the right approach you
should take because if it if you seem
like it's it's bothering you then
they're going to keep doing it oh yeah
so I thought it would just fizzle out
it's still it's still here shockingly
there's only two people named Patrick
forward in Boston really let you get any
I'm kid I work i'm sure those high works
with another Patrick Ford I mean in a
company that had a few hundred people
yeah but I worked with someone with the
exact same name as me no I think if we
were to look it up I've it you know
what's insane I mean part of this is
because of just the population of New
York City but I was one of my band mates
when I was in New York was Eddie Torres
okay and Eddie you would assume is short
for what Edward Edwin or Edmund right
what
we already talking about I think the
number one would be it short for Edward
but with Eddie it was short for Edwin
and he told me that once he looked up
how many Edwin torrez's there were
registered to vote just in New York City
and it was way too many to even count so
then he said I decided to look how many
Edwin his middle initial torrez's are
there right so let's imagine just for a
second i'm not going to actually say
what his middle name is i don't want
someone to find Eddie and start
harassing him but let's say his middle
initial was X right he looked up how
many Edwin x torrez's are there
registered to vote in New York so this
does include doesn't include people not
registered and kids there were 11 Edwin
x torrez's registered to vote just in
New York City alone you wouldn't think
if i said to you how common is the name
Edwin X Torres that just in New York
City there were 11 people with that name
yeah i mean what's the population of New
York 8 million people or something and
you know there's it's very diverse so I
think pretty much any name that you plug
in there there's going to be people with
the exact same name as you yep yep not
david patten de don't really there is
another david pakman with a different
middle initial I've seen him works in
New York City it doesn't live in New
York City I'd be known him for a while
actually he's probably not too happy
that whenever he searches to save on the
internet you show up all over the plane
we both get each other's Google Alerts
interestingly enough no the Patrick Ford
that I worked with they sent him my tax
returns once oh you don't want so that's
the problem yes you definitely don't
want that okay that does it on the bonus
show today the Netherlands keeps closing
prisons because they don't have enough
prisoners not a problem that we have in
the United States also seven percent of
Catholic priests in Australia are
accused of sexually abusing children and
more david pakman.com slash membership
don't miss today's bonus show